on both sides of the atlantic central
banks are tackling the problem of
inflation rising prices have become a
major problem as economies rebound from
the depths of the pandemic here in
germany some people have seen their
heating bills double in just the past
year and prices are also surging for
fuel and food
three euros and 95 cents for a head of
cauliflower
other produce is also more expensive
than a year ago
food prices have risen by four and a
half percent on average in the past year
something that berlin greengrocer
mahmoud thomas has noticed
people are hesitant which is
understandable because everyone is
suffering financially right now and
we're noticing it here people are
leaving things off their shopping list
across the way at this sausage stand
kahola baya has had to raise her prices
by up to 30 percent many things that she
needs have become more expensive
the cooking oil has increased by 30
within two months the tomato paste by 20
everything has gotten more expensive
gabi the woman who runs the stand next
to hers is retired she earns a little
extra by selling hats she can hardly
afford the inflated food prices and has
begun going to a food bank
this way i pay a fraction for my
groceries but otherwise if i were to buy
groceries like before it would be really
hard to afford them
fuel prices have risen even more sharply
premium gasoline now costs 41 percent
more than a year ago
and the price of heating oil has doubled
the causes include both the pandemic and
a new carbon emissions tax the european
central bank believes the inflation
surge is temporary and due to the
effects of the pandemic it expects
inflation will be lower next year
yeah with prices and the pandemic you
need a booster not only for your immune
system but also for your wallet that's
what my colleague rob watts has been
saying from dw business rob yeah i agree
with you there
the european central bank
they're trying to do something about
inflation what are they doing well one
of the key ways in which you can tackle
inflation if you are a central bank is
because you've got control of interest
rates is to to raise them because what
that does is it makes it less attractive
to borrow money and more attractive to
save money which means people spend less
and when people spend less prices don't
rise as much because you don't have this
uh
demand and supply issue that leads to
inflation but the ecb has said that it's
not ready to increase uh interest rates
just yet they're at zero right they're
at historic lows are zero and they're
not going any higher than that just yet
even though inflation is out you know
over five percent in some areas the
ecb's target is two percent
but
i i've spoken to an expert about this
today and he insists that the ecb is
taking this too slowly because not only
is he saying it's not going to increase
rates now it says during 2022 it can't
see itself increasing rates at all then
either even though it is it is
forecasting uh you know inflation of
over three percent then so it's still
well above its target however it isn't
doing nothing to tackle inflation what
the ecb has just announced is that it is
going to be phasing out its massive uh
pandemic purchasing program which is
basically an economic stimulus that was
worth 1.85 trillion euros and that
should hopefully do
something to stop the outrageous
spending okay i mean so i'm wondering
how does the european central bank's
approach compare to other central banks
thinking of the bank of england the
federal reserve banks it's good that you
mentioned both of those too actually
because we've heard from the bank of
england which is a big deal because
they're you know they're the custodians
of the british pound which is which is
influential and they aren't doing the
same as the european central bank
they've actually announced that they're
going to increase rates right now to
0.25
which doesn't sound like a big deal but
actually when you consider that they
haven't raised interest rates at all for
the past three years you see that that
is something that is remarkable and it
has surprised investors today but one of
the reasons is yeah it's behaving slow
yeah exactly yeah it is because we've
we've been living in an area of falling
rates so this is this is a real change
and uh one of the things that uh is
behind that is that you know inflation
is worse in the uk than it is in the
eurozone so you can see why there's more
pressure there for them to do that but
then we've also heard from the federal
reserve in the united states the central
bank there and they're also like the ecb
not increasing rates yet however they
have said that they expect to do it
three times next year and the ecb said
it doesn't expect to do it at all next
year so they're certainly seeming a bit
more radical on this so what does that
tell us in about 22 2022 i mean people
want to know that prices are going to
come down
yeah well
they probably will eventually but we
can't say that it's not going to be more
inflation through at least the first few
months of 2022 because we've still got
people spending more still got demand
rising people are buying more especially
for christmas yeah absolutely and people
are getting out and about more they want
to buy stuff because they've had this
pent-up demand over the past couple of
years but the problem is that supply
chains can't keep up producers can't
make the stuff as fast as it's being
sold and that leads to rising prices
which leads to inflation and that's not
going anywhere so we're
not out of the inflation woods yet yeah
we have to get through the holiday
season and into
january we'll talk again come february
make sure things are pretty
all right rob as always thank you